some conservatives are sick of playing
pretend
some thousands of
conservatives Catholics just showed up
outside of Dodger Stadium because you
know we had previously mentioned that
the Dodgers were going to honor a
an actual satanic drag troop a
Blasphemous sacrilegious satanic drag
troop whose entire raise on debt is to
mock our Lord Jesus Christ
that group was being honored at Dodger
Stadium they're called The Sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence so they mock not
only our Lord but they mock nuns who
worship our Lord and so the Dodgers
initially said okay we probably
shouldn't honor the satanic drag group
and then later on they said no actually
we should and I always should sorry I
forgot our national religion is the
rainbow okay yeah we're gonna we're
gonna honor the satanic drag troop and
so thousands of Catholics turned up
outside
and and protested
you can see there's lots of great videos
and unlike when the Liberals show up in
protest they didn't burn anything down
they didn't make the place look
disgusting they just
they just held up signs it stopped this
kind of hate
believe believe in Jesus you know really
nice basic stuff holding up beautiful
banners beautiful pictures of Our Lord
crucifixes
they're just man I love conservatives
Christians so much it just even when
they're taking to the streets they're
just orderly put together
it looked nice
record but they're showing up on mass I
mean if you were a big lib
you were going to the Dodgers game
you would probably be surprised that
there were even that many Catholics in
Southern California that is a show
of numbers and power and it's something
that the American people need to start
doing a little bit more because
increasingly you're seeing a Divergence
of opinion between the people and the
elite
the big Divergence of opinion that we're
seeing now is not so much left versus
right or Republican versus Democrat it's
people versus Elite that's how you're
seeing the emergence populist candidates
like Donald Trump like Robert Kennedy Jr
we're kind of Crossing party lines in a
way that we haven't seen in the last few
Decades of American politics you're
seeing the the deplorables the
irredeemable people you know the ones
the bitter clingers that Obama and
Hillary Clinton made fun of those people
don't neatly fit exactly into Republican
or Democrat they're moving much more in
the Republican Camp right now
because the Democrats have now become
the party of the elite
so we've got the numbers on our sides on
a whole host of issues I mean to use
just this example that the drag queen
stuff and the anti-catholic hate
the American people are overwhelmingly
on our side but because we don't have
that much power anymore because a small
number of elite liberals control the
political process now it's it's unclear
how how much influence our our numbers
are actually going to get us so we've
got to show up
that that does matter I was reminded of
the covid vaccines do you remember with
the coveted vaccines
Joe Biden said I'm not going to have a
vaccine mandate I'm not going to have a
vaccine mandate I'm not gonna have a
vaccine mandate okay there's a mandate
and how did that happen
because Biden was waiting fauci was
waiting for the number of people who had
already received one shot of the vaccine
to reach a significant threshold that
there wouldn't be total pushback so then
the moment when it was just 10 of people
had gotten the vaccine
Biden knew that a federal mandate was a
losing proposition
and 20 then 30 then 40 then once you get
enough people all of a sudden you say
okay now we've got it
same thing with fauci during the the
run-up to the vaccine he was asked what
percentage of people need to be
vaccinated to achieve herd immunity and
he said oh no listen here listen here I
think the total percentage is 70 one day
with 70 one day was 80 one it was 60 it
kept moving and found she was asked wait
hold on why does this keep moving and he
admitted he said I'm paraphrasing here
but he said something to the effect of
because look part of this is politically
publicly I've got to convince people to
get the vaccine so we move that we
adjust the thresholds a little bit to do
that okay the numbers really matter the
enthusiasm really matters if we show
these guys that we mean business they
are going to back off at least for a
time people are raving about genucel
skin care Jessica from Huntsville
Alabama says my skin looks so soft and
clear I've seen a reduced number of fine
lines and dark spots I found a new
lifetime product absolutely love it can
you sell skin care uses a one of a kind
proprietary flower base developed by the
founder and pharmacist who is a great
guy by the way it's also comes along
with rare Botanical extracts and
Powerful antioxidants for skin care
results that work guaranteed I said I
would not endorse the product if I could
not try it if I were not impressed by
the product and also fellas I know
sometimes men are a little skeptical of
getting into Cosmetics too much even
slightly more men than women use
genuscal and for good reason geniusell's
most popular package is available to you
today for 70 off 7-0 at genucel.com
knowlesyt join millions of happy
customers who've already fallen in love
with the results Plus for a limited time
yet genu sells probiotic extract
moisturizer free with every most popular
package go to geniusell.com knowlesyt
genucel.com
knowlesyt great news coming out of
Gallup
it's a lot of great news on the horizon
about the American people even as the
American government seems to decay
Americans are overwhelmingly pro-life
according to a Gallup news survey
released this week
just 37 percent of Americans think
abortion should be legal in the second
or third trimester of pregnancy
only 22 percent believe that it should
be legal in the third trimester so well
over three quarters of Americans say you
you really should ban abortion in the
third trimester and about two-thirds say
that you should ban abortion in the
second trimester too so you've got at
least you know roughly two-thirds of
Americans who say abortion should only
be legal in the first trimester
now unfortunately
the majority of Americans believe
abortion should be legal in the first
three months of pregnancy that's 69 of
Americans so that's the highest
percentage since Gallup began tracking
the trend so you've now got you've got
more Americans than ever who think
abortion should be legal in the first
trimester but you've got a cratering
number of Americans who think that
abortion should be legal in the second
and third trimester
what does that tell us
I think it's basically good news in that
if you were able to ban abortion in
America in the second and third
trimester that would be a great
improvement over what we've got now so
I'll take it
but it also shows you one of the
downsides of democratic lowercase D
Democratic politics which is that it
tends toward incoherence
you ever hear about the independent
voter
in America in democracies we always
exalt the independent voter
but the independent voter
very often is independent because his
political views don't make any sense so
he'll say
I don't know he'll say I'm a pro
I'm Pro abortion
well I guess in this case you just say
I'm pro-abortion in the first trimester
but not in the third trimester it's the
same baby why is it okay to murder the
baby at one point but not another point
or you'll you'll see someone say
I'm in favor of transgenderism but not
for transiting the kids well okay if
you're in favor of transgenderism
then you're making a claim about human
nature
and if if that claim about human nature
is sure it's true of the kids also
or you'll you'll see someone say
I'm in favor of uh
I don't know any any number of sort of
issues uh they'll they'll be a little
bit confused they'll support some social
policies but not certain economic
policies and it gets a little bit
jumbled
up
now a nice consequence of the hostility
between the people and the elite that
we're seeing increasing
is that
Elite opinion
in this liberal establishment is pretty
reliably wrong on all of these issues on
sexuality on immigration on the economy
on foreign policy the elite opinion if
you open up the pages of the New York
Times The Washington Post you find
whatever the opinion is there you can 99
times out of 100 be confident that that
opinion is wrong and you should have the
opposite opinion
which means that
as the elites become more and more
radical more and more corrupt more and
more wrong and the people increasingly
view the elites as hostile to them
the American people are going to become
more conservative
as we're seeing reflected in the polls
on abortion on sexual matters on
education on even economic matters
on foreign policy uh you're seeing a
conservatizing of the American people
will that be reflected in the polls the
question is how much power do the people
have boy what a great clip that was huh
if you want the whole show including the
stuff we're not allowed to talk about on
here you know like a certain issue that
we're not allowed to talk about head on
over to daily wire
plus.com right now and also head and
check out the Michael Knowles show at
Twitter M Knowles show we'll see you
there